[Music]
Victor logic loves books his dream is to
build the biggest library between Vienna
and Istanbul in Serbia's capital
Belgrade so he's collecting and
preserving as many books as he can
he receives no state funding and has
only a small number of assistants but
what he lacks in staff he makes up for
in passion although not everyone is
happy about lodges plans
[Music]
[Music]
storage crates as far as the eye can see
this is Victor lodges book warehouse
located in the air raid shelter of a
school in Belgrade the passages are so
narrow you can barely squeeze through
them this is a perfect place for hiding
Mozza CH has already collected over 1
million books but it will still be some
time before he reaches his goal of
assembling the region's largest library
Victor Lazaro when he was a child over
the years he remained on good terms with
school officials and that's why they let
him use the basement to store his books
today the collection fills four large
rooms a lot of these books and magazines
date from before the breakup of
Yugoslavia but they're running out of
space some books will have to go but it
isn't easy for Leslie and his colleague
Stefan to choose which ones you can
still use all of these but look
carefully first this can all go but if
something valuable gets thrown out it's
going to be your fault sometimes you
really get on my nerves yeah yeah a few
years ago Laza JH seriously injured his
back lifting so many crates today he has
a few assistants still moving the books
around is a real challenge at the worst
moment one of the worst in my life for
sure was when we received some huge
donation about five trucks of books one
whole library just collapsed and they
kicked out the books and we took them
over it was I don't even know how many
boxes I guess about two thousand boxes
at once in one day and
it didn't have enough workers to do this
job it's impossible and what I did I
invited all my friends neighbors even
people on the street was passing by we
were begging them you know to help us to
bring it in here Victor's colleagues
Stefan and Zoran helped carry a few
crates up from the basement the books
are being donated to a prison in
Belgrade the crates will be loaded into
this old car which often breaks down but
logic can't afford a new car this is the
home of Lhasa Chaz parents a few hundred
metres from the school in 2010 this is
where he founded the Association ugly
gut the cornerstone of the library
project the Association sponsors a book
and travel museum he doesn't earn any
money from it
Lhasa is a lawyer by profession and
invests almost everything here ins in
this project he also inherited a large
sum and he put that into the book
project too large could afford to live
comfortably but he spends his money on
books his parents don't quite understand
that it's love for books and culture and
literature and believe that we are doing
something it is truly important not only
for this country but it has even bigger
importance broader report importance for
the world and at least for this region
Mozza jazz project now receives
financial support from a few wealthy
donors the extra money could help the
museum grow to 10 rooms la such conduct
guided tours through the collection he
wants the project to become a cultural
beacon for the entire Balkan region his
collection already rivals that of the
country's biggest libraries
nice fragrance yes but it'll change over
time Serbia's government institutions
don't seem very interested in lazarus'
work in fact they've ignored it some
visitors have criticized that like
culture journalist Ivana mackovic
why are the collections of famous
artists like the actor Pavlovic or the
famous poet Miu drug pavlovic on display
here and not in the National Library or
the National Film Archive but if they're
in safe hands here and visitors can see
and touch them which is very unusual
then why not Josh Turner this is a
refugee shelter in bhagavad yeah
60 kilometers south of Belgrade la
search will occasionally drop off some
books here most of them in foreign
languages here are some books
books offer a welcome diversion from the
monotonous daily routine at the refugee
shelter fatima from Shiraz in Iran is
pleased to receive a book in her native
language Farsi this place has its
problems
but we can try to make the most of it by
keeping busy with things like reading
more than a hundred refugees live at the
shelter many are from Afghanistan or
Iran la search doesn't receive a lot of
books in Farsi but when he does he
brings most of them here you know it is
very important for intellectuals and
also for children to have attacks with
their own culture with their own
indentity it also makes them feel more
welcomed here it makes them feel like at
home so I think it is very important for
them yes hello dr. Lesage who's calling
hello can you hear me
a little later Lisette returns to
Belgrade he's trying to secure an
unusually large donation of books but he
has to be faster than the public
libraries and he is most of the time but
if he doesn't move quickly the
collection will be given to another
institution or the books may even end up
in the garbage dump
oh this donation what kind of books in
it well this was one of the extremely
famous litter TV and theater critic so
there are there are excellent books
about TV about theater art it's amazing
larges staff are just as crazy about
books as he is they earn only one year
Oh 40 per hour that's just a bit more
than Serbia's minimum wage plus they
work overtime and put in irregular hours
la search has been working on his book
project for eight years now word about
the project has spread and he's getting
more and more calls from people who want
to donate books that had belonged to
deceased relatives his schedule is
pretty hectic whenever he needs a break
la such likes to come to this meadow
near the belgrade fortress it's one of
his favorite spots in his hometown from
here he has a perfect view of where the
Sava river joins the Danube he has
enjoyed visiting the park since he was a
teenager when he came here to meet girls
well it's a place where I spend most of
my teenage years like after school my
school is in nearby we would come here
and hang out here so I have a lot of
nice memories la searches house is also
his office and a place to store books
but the fact that he's put all of his
money time and energy into the book
project has had a negative effect on his
personal life three years ago his
fiancee left him
they'd been together for some time but
she said she just couldn't take it
anymore
because there was no money not only for
workers there was no money for fuel if
someone donates books I would you know
put the books in the car and would not
have enough fuel to bring them here and
there was not enough money women for
food I mean we weren't actually hungry
but it was always you know problematic
if it will be enough for everything or
not la Serge believes that his book
project is carrying on a family
tradition his great-grandfather loved
books and some of his ancestors even
founded a library but the fact remains
that he no longer has much room for
himself in his own house still that
doesn't bother him I give everything I
have and most of the people in obligate
the founders even the workers they
actually have to invest themselves to
keep this project running at this
perception they're celebrating the
addition of some new storage rooms la
stitch has made a name for himself in
literary circles the guests here include
several prominent writers and other
well-known people it's networking for a
good cause preserving books
[Music]
Victor logic in another step toward his
goal of building a huge library but he
also knows that he's got a lot of work
ahead of him
[Music]